you know i thought they'd pick some
competent golfers
and then i saw the match-up
why is tom the only one wearing pants
two words
varicose veins
josh's biggest fear vegetables a coin
toss
[Laughter]
tom brady combine picture good there
it's a little thank you guys call that a
love tab call that a love tab ask josh
if he's ever seen one of these oh
josh have you ever seen one of these
you know what that is he's on his third
outfit change of the day so
he might have just kind of changed again
i don't know we'll see
it could be his fourth
then listen these football players
should have bought a bunch of helmets
out here for these fans there are some
humans whose lives would be in danger if
i stepped up to this team this is absurd
oh jj once you hit one person they're
all the same after that
i hope there's a waiver on the back of
the ticket this guy's pretty good at
golf that's what happens when you don't
go to otas you just
tough start for the youngsters you guys
aren't surprised by this are you a
little chunky i call that a little josh
alleny
wow oh little josh allen
oh really well that's probably not a
good idea because we're only playing 12.
whatever
that's a valid
point i prepared my whole life for this
moment actually not the super bowl this
okay i'm not all just muscle and
and brawn there's some brains here on
the strip ooh oh that's not going to
account for that long drive just any
fairway
doesn't count oh man just over shaquille
o'neal length
geez
an interesting way to think of it that's
the one good thing about doing golf man
i had to be around that idiot
we had in this beautiful day on the
guard
it's more beautiful when shaq's not here
heads up
bust something oh
that's done to her neighbor don't
don't mess with the moneymaker
they always want to mess with the money
maker this ain't easy y'all
charles if i make this right here will
you jump in the water
yes i will thank you oh yeah you make
this i'll jump in the water you have my
word mr mahomes do it for pat all right
let's do it
gave it a good hit up there oh this is
probably good
come on
wow
we were so close to seeing this guy in a
waterfall chuck tall started unbuttoning
his shirt